throughout history and across all
cultures whether it's a tribal ritual
the two-step or twerking we all have a
personal way of expressing ourselves on
the dance floor or at home in front of
the mirror and while some of us are
seemingly a lot better than others the
question remains are these expressions
actually individual or part of an
embedded human code
why are we so drawn to dance and is
really equivalent to a human mating call
more importantly does dancing increase
your potential to get some from a
viewers perspective dance can be
pleasurable to watch for many of the
same reasons music is enjoyable to
listen to but it was the science legend
Charles Darwin who first suggested that
dance could be part of mating rituals
and entangled with the evolution and
survival of our species but if this is
true the ability to dance must somehow
relate to the ability to survive and
reproduce
so does it it turns out that early
humans who were coordinated symmetrical
and rhythmic were seen as more viable to
a mate because these traits were often
linked to survival the ability to run
faster defend against fright and
ultimately survive and dancing just
happens to be an outward manifestation
and display of many of these qualities a
quick external way of documenting and
proving your fitness in order to attract
a mate this desire to dance can even be
seen in babies as early as five months
old
bopping to a beat in fact many species
use dance or movement to swoon the
opposite sex from spiders to a variety
of birds and even bees which use dance
moves to communicate entire messages but
why are humans compelled to dance to
music it likely has something to do with
the fact that many of the brain's reward
systems are directly connected to the
motor areas for example music stimulates
the cerebellum at the base of the brain
which is involved in the timing and
coordination of movement in a
contemporary sense dance is known to
shown confidence and fearlessness and
sometimes intoxication but most
importantly movements associated with
good dancing are indicative of good
health and reproductive potential and in
many cases the human courtship ritual in
our natural habitat of a nightclub
mirrors that of animals in the wild
this gives being an animal on the dance
floor a new meaning
except our liquid courage doesn't come
from the local waterhole ironically many
men feel as though they can't dance or
that dancing isn't for them
but in most animals the male's must
impress the female so what is good
dancing men scientists have actually
studied which male dance movements were
most attractive to women
interestingly it was seen that twisting
bending and fluid movements of the core
body region like the torso neck and head
garnered the most positive attention
from women showing variability
flexibility and creativity was perceived
as good dancing on the other hand
repetitive rigid and twitchy movements
weren't particularly attractive
sometimes called dad dancing and
truthfully your dad probably dances a
little slower and more rigid than his
youthful counterpart because simply put
he isn't as youthful or fit anymore so
whether you're in a club a bar or your
own living room engage and embrace your
animal instincts and if you're asked
where you got those moves just say
millions of years of evolution have led
to this dance baby
who knew science could be so groovy
this episode of ASAP science is
supported by audible.com the leading
provider of audiobooks with over 100,000
downloadable titles across all types of
literature if you'd like to learn more
about evolution I recommend the book the
greatest show on earth by Richard
Dawkins you can download this audiobook
or another of your choice for free at
audible.com/asap special thanks to
audible for making these videos possible
and offering you a free audiobook at
audible.com/asap and subscribe for more
weekly science videos